lockdown hypocrisy from democratic
leaders as states
ramp up restrictions and shutdowns
california lawmakers are reportedly
going to hawaii
for a week while the state imposes new
restrictions on 94 percent of residents
and then there is governor gavin newsom
apologizing for breaking his own covet
rules by going
to a fancy french restaurant
i made a bad mistake instead of sitting
down
i should have stood up and i got to own
that and so i want to apologize to you
because i need to preach and practice
not just preach but you know who's not
apologizing
new york governor andrew cuomo watch
we will make mistakes in life
we try not to but we do the key
is to be strong and secure enough to
admit your mistakes
and admit your shortcomings don't get
defensive
denying the mistake only assures
repeating the mistake all right greg so
if your state
relocks down big time who can afford to
fly to hawaii
well the people with a lot of cash this
is the
one great thing about the lockdown is
that it reveals why people get into
politics in the first place
to become immune from the policies that
they put on us
uh think about like think about war like
if your dad is a powerful politician
you probably won't get drafted if we had
a draft
or maybe you would be you'd able to get
an interest-free loan for a house
or maybe you just get a really cushy job
somewhere because your dad
can pull some strings but we don't know
about that stuff because
you know politics they place a wall
between the public
and the secret power that they hold and
that's one of the neat things about
trump
was that he pulled that wall away you
learned about hunter biden
so the lockdowns revealed the
hypocrisies of newsome lori lightfoot
chris cuomo
uh you can't beat andrew cuomo andrew
cuomo chris
i was thinking of chris and you know
they both you know but um
you're violating the rules that you
place on others you can't do that
anymore because we all see it
we're in a world now where we see it
yeah dana like greg said it's tough when
you see these people
egregiously violating the lockdowns that
they imposed on the rest yeah
so my mom sent me a note just a moment
ago and she's not mad about it you know
the
colorado is locking down again they have
a situation but that
the governor there governor polis hasn't
done anything like this right he
i think he really has practiced what he
preached and i think his you know
approval rating is pretty high because
of it
i also think that um just do the right
thing for you
and your family and your health don't
think that the government is going to do
it for you
i just feel bad for all of these small
businesses juan that
had recovered from the lockdowns over
the summer we're just getting back up
onto their feet
and then in places like michigan
shutting everything down again
well i think it's pretty clear the only
way that we're going to get the economy
rolling again is to get the virus under
control
but you know i think you should call out
politicians who behave in a hypocritical
manner i think they
really hurt themselves and hurt their
credibility so
that's their fault but i do think and i
said this yesterday
these are the right policies these are
good policies and they shouldn't
distract
they're misbehaving shouldn't distract
from the idea that we have to try to
protect ourselves and our families i
mean that to me that's a reality
yes yesterday i read something came from
a mississippi newspaper mississippi top
official so these are republicans jesse
we don't want to see grandma
thanksgiving and bury her at christmas
that's pretty serious are you going to
have grandma over for thanksgiving
we're having a very distant thanksgiving
where everyone i'm going to the dollar
tree
and everyone is going to have their own
utensils like no one will touch anything
i come from a family of germaphobe so
we're all pretty good with this
we you know we really don't want to talk
to each other sitting next to each other
so this is far for the course
uh but what i will say is as california
lawmakers who are going to the kehlani
in maui
it's a beautiful resort like i would
love to go to the kealani the rooms
start at 600
a night it's on this incredible strip
in wailea it's like one of the best
parts of hawaii
why wouldn't they want to go so yes we
all want to go we all want to go
somewhere
so why don't you have a big rethink on
this why do you think that you are
immune
from the virus and we have to be
punished because we're the dumb little
dirt people
we are dumb little dirt people who would
also like to frolic
in the hawaiian sun thank you wow
dumb little dirt people that's us